DYLAN THOMAS: Hello, and welcome
to What In The World.
This is a regular show where
Geo Googlers dip into
interesting Enterprise
Maps-related topics and share
the results with you.
I'm Dylan Thomas.
I'm a Geo Enterprise
community manager.
And joining me today is Ryan
Thomas, who works with our
Enterprise customers on getting
up and running with
our Geo products.
Hi, Ryan.
RYAN THOMAS: Hi, Dylan.
How are you?
DYLAN THOMAS: I'm
good, thanks.
I'm looking forward
to the show today.
You're going to be
talking with us
about Google Maps Engine.
And more to the point, how to
get GME layers up and running
and visible in Google Maps
JavaScript API, right?
RYAN THOMAS: That's right.
Specifically, I'm going to be
talking about MapsEngineLayer
and DynamicMapsEngineLayer.
And because that's been such a
tongue twister for me, I'm
going to refer to it as MEL
and DMEL during the
presentation.
DYLAN THOMAS: That's
an awesome idea.
RYAN THOMAS: Let's
take it away.
And we'll look at
a presentation
that we have today.
So this is what we're going
to go through today.
We're going to talk about what
are MEL and DMEL, why they
were created, what are the
benefits to users, go over a
little bit more information,
and then do a quick
demonstration on how
to use them.
So what are MEL and DMEL?
Well, Google has the excellent
location data hosting service
of Google Maps Engine, which
you're probably familiar
about, where you can upload
your map data, style, and
store your data in the cloud.
Google also has the map-making
tool of JavaScript API, and
MEL and DMEL are essentially
to the link between them.
Now, using those, you can
easily put a map on your
website that shows
your GME content.
So why were they created?
MEL and DMEL were originally
created because there wasn't a
concise and simple way to put
styled GME data on a non-GME
map, an example of Maps API.
Since customers went through the
effort to style their data
in GME, they didn't want to have
to repeat the effort in
the Maps API JavaScript.
So enter MEL and DMEL.
And MEL was created to make
it easy to visualize your
content on a map.
And prior to MEL, the only way
to add GME content was to draw
one feature at a time, which,
as you can imagine, would
become pretty cumbersome
and time consuming.
DMEL was created to make the
experience for your end user
much richer.
And you can add styling changes
which reacts to the
user, such as mouseover, which
we'll see later on during the
demonstration.
So what are the benefits
to users?
Essentially, this is a powerful
integration between
our Geo products of
Google Maps Engine
and JavaScript API.
And it's a simple and easy
way to visualize your
GME data on a map.
And what's nice about is there's
little to no coding
experience necessary
for users.
This is all accomplished in
approximately three lines of
code, which is very simple.
And just giving a little
bit more information.
This does not work with Internet
Explorer 8 or earlier
versions, so that's just
something to be aware of.
And these are several links
with documentation on
MapsEngineLayer,
DynamicMapsEngineLayer, and
then OAuth 2.0 Playground.
And these links will be embedded
within the video for
you to go to at your leisure as
you come across any issues
or questions.
So let's move into the
demonstration.
As you can see, right now I
am in Google Maps Engine.
And let's say we created a layer
in Google Maps Engine,
and the data was about
the 2010 census.
Now, if we go over to the right,
we can click on this
map to view a draft of
our data in GME.
As I zoom out and then zoom in,
we can see the data, or
the layer, that was placed
upon the map here in GME.
Now, if we click on the map,
we can get some information
from the layer that
we've added.
So now we want to get this
layer, and place this on a map
on a website.
So the thing that you want
to do is go to the upper
right-hand corner--
and you can see this button in
the upper right-hand corner it
says access links.
And if you click on that, you
have the asset ID, which is
the same as the layer ID.
Now, you can copy
this layer ID .
And then from here, we'll move
into some actual script that
we have already filled out.
And now that we're in the
script, you can see if there's
a place for the layer ID.
And this is where you would
place the layer ID that we
just copied and pasted from
Google Maps Engine.
And as we scroll down--
Now, this is a little more
complicated than it normally
would be, because in the
demonstration I'm going to be
showing to maps side by side,
but it's really only a few
lines of code.
And you can see we have
the DMEL code here.
And then just below that,
we have the MEL code.
DYLAN THOMAS: So that looks
really simple, Ryan.
All you're doing is calling
each of those classes.
And you're just passing in the
layer ID you go, and then
linking it to one or other
of the maps, right?
That's it.
RYAN THOMAS: Exactly.
So now that we've looked at the
script, let's go and take
a look at what the maps
will look like.
These are the two maps that
we're now displaying.
Now, the map on the left is from
MapsEngineLayer and is a
static map.
The map the right is from
DynamicMapsEngineLayer and
it's more dynamic
and interactive.
So let's zoom in on the
map on the left.
And we're headed
toward Kansas.
Now, let's just scroll
over our data.
See, we can click on it and
still get the same information
that was in Google
Maps Engine.
Now, let's go over to the
map on the right.
Zoom in back to Kansas.
Now this time, this map is a
little bit more dynamic and it
has a mouseover effect.
As you can see, as we scroll
over some of the data in the
layer, it'll light up.
And so this is just a very
simple example of ways to make
your maps more interactive for
your users, and make it a
richer experience for them.
DYLAN THOMAS: The key
difference here as I
understand it, then, is your
MapsEngineLayer, or MEL, as we
just renamed it, is the left.
And that's really getting
traditional map tiles as
images that are being created
in Maps Engine, right?
So that we're downloading map
tiles and displaying them.
And that's why you have to click
on a feature to go get
the feature information
on the left.
But on the right, we're actually
streaming the vectors
from the MapsEngineLayer.
Engine And that's why when
they're down on the client, we
have more of this
interactivity.
RYAN THOMAS: That's
exactly right.
And this is what MEL and DMEL
can do for you by taking the
Google Maps Engine data and
displaying them for you with
the JavaScript API.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
So it looks like it when you're
hovering there, I saw
the change of color.
So obviously, you can listen
to events with
DynamicMapsEngineLayer, like
mouseover or onclick,
obviously and then change an
individual feature as well.
RYAN THOMAS: That's right.
DYLAN THOMAS: Well, thanks for
showing that, Ryan I do have a
couple of follow on questions.
This is, after all, the
Enterprise folks who are
listening in.
So one of things I wanted to ask
was about authentication
and authorization.
I know that OAuth 2.0 is the
protocol we use to provide
authorization for Map Layers
so that access control data
isn't just wide open
to the internet.
Are there some resources
available or a place a
customer can go to learn
more about that?
RYAN THOMAS: There are.
And that's a really good
question which a
lot of people have.
In the links that I showed
earlier in the presentation,
there was a link to an example
in the developers page where
it will have a JavaScript
example about OAuth 2.0.
And another link is for the
OAuth 2.0 Playground, where
you can go and learn more about
OAuth 2.0 and how to
utilize it.
And if you have additional
questions, feel more than
welcome to get in touch with
us through the community to
help answer any specific
questions you may have.
DYLAN THOMAS: Good point.
Thanks for plugging the
community, there, Ryan.
That's pretty nice.
So the two pieces you mentioned
there is the OAuth
Playground, where you can learn
more about OAuth just as
a base protocol and the approach
to doing this.
And the second part is a
specific example for Maps
Engine, right?
RYAN THOMAS: Exactly.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
One other thing I was thinking
about as you were hovering
over the map feature, there, is
you're changing the color,
but there's no reason you
couldn't just call any kind of
code at that point, right?
You hover over a feature, you
could show a picture or go get
some Wikipedia data about
that county in Kansas.
I know that a lot of customers
on the DynamicMapsEngineLayer
also want to then go and query
the Google Maps Engine via the
API as well.
Are there any limitations that
they should think about as
they're streaming these vectors
down to the client
using the Maps API and then
querying back to the feature
in Maps Engine?
RYAN THOMAS: That's
a good point.
The possibilities are
pretty great on what
you can do with that.
But people should just
be aware that the
limit is 1,000 features.
And so going over that, you
may run into some issues.
DYLAN THOMAS: So you're saying
that there's no limitation on
the number of things that Maps
API could display, at least
today in terms of--
we're not going to say
a million, that may
be too many, right?
But the GME API itself is what's
used to make this thing
work, and that has a limitation
today of 1,000
features per request, right?
RYAN THOMAS: Exactly.
As long as that doesn't go up,
GME is essentially doing the
heavy lifting.
And so 1,000 features in GME
is the limit as of today.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
Well, Ryan, I wanted to really
thank you for taking the time
to show us some tips and tricks
there on MEL and DMEL
today, so thank you.
And we'll make sure that this
video is available online for
those of you who couldn't
watch it live, and we'll
include the links.
And I want to reiterate
Ryan's offer
to help in the community.
So if you do have further
questions, just get in touch
with us and let us know.
Thanks very much.